my name is kristina virginskikh i come from kherson for the first time went to the maidan on november 24 by profession a journalist maidan turned everything upside down for me i started running my own facebook project that talked about the people of maidan i want to tell you a story that changed the entrance of the revolution for me in general, including personally, I met one guy on the Maidan and his name is Seryozha Nigoyan, this is a 20-year-old guy from the Dnipropetrovsk region, an Armenian and I noticed him on the Maidan for a long time because we had a tent from the Maltese cuisine, they prepared delicious tea there, the best tea, as it seems to me, on maidan and he helped to chop wood there java every day I saw him chopping firewood I noticed him he has a very bright appearance and then one day I met him and talked and wrote down his story he told how he first went to Dnepropetrovsk because he thought that Maidan was in Dnepropetrovsk when he saw that there was no Maidan, he came to Kyiv and on January 22 I wake up and read
messages that
there are the first killed on Grushevsky or that
among the first killed is Sergey Nigoyan when
I saw the photo I realized that this is
the guy I wrote about and I
was just insanely shocked because
the guy is 20 years old and he has his whole life
ahead of him, nowhere is he
anything bad  there was a weapon or
something like that he
really came to fight and this is the
first death and it changed everything for me
I even thought then to close the project
but decided to continue it